salut qu'au conseil de classe de
géraldine match dès qu'une chose à dire
bravo c'est tout merci
béchir y nom alors je vais te dire les
notes un kit a émis la plus mauvaise
note c'était nicolas tu l'aimés 4.4
c'est suite au débat là sur le tennis la
semaine dernière j'ai besoin par exemple
un peu méprisante haussier tchèque avait
ce côté là tu l'avais mis à turin avait
mis un jour elle sera chroniqueuse lui
mettre à dos
[Applaudissements]
c'était valérie bénaïm ouais c'est 1909
pasqua parce que quand je suis parti un
peu j'ai levé le pied
c'était un petit oiseau quand je suis
revenu c'était un aigle elle assuré
ouais survolé l'année mais c'est vrai
que ce serait franchement amer vous êtes
donc vous êtes un mec je vous jure que
c'est un fou c'est vraiment une autre
porte parole dans cette émission je
trouve ça un peu votre chef
oui je devais désigner un chef dans mon
équipe maintenant c'est jérémy de manier
ces roms et les chutes je vais casse
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
déjà lors bernard montiel c'est dingue
ses droits c'est fou hein pourquoi la
bravo pour vous qu'est ce que j'aimerais
vous êtes sympathique je suis content de
vous voir
non mais c'est fou hein et de seconde
des lycées
ça fait des années qu'il sert à rien à
la télé il est toujours là sa carrière
sur dur ya des sourires de la vieille
dame et au bac c'est déjà pas mal
il avait raison si on pouvait on prédit
mistral gagnant
oui vous reviendrez pas la rentrée ça tu
veux plus là